we got Detroit's finest in here
baby money Easy Money [ __ ] go watch the
full interview we got but right now
we're about to get to These Bars man
look at it the choice on fire right now
this guy is uh one of the latest on QC
one of the hardest out of the city let's
run let's go crazy bro
[Music]
Easy Money [ __ ] man as long as my [ __ ]
crumbs
[Music]
200 on my neck and my wrist I love to
flex on this [ __ ] I put Rock cart techno
trip
yeah
200 on my neck and my wrist so I love to
flex on the [ __ ] I put rock hard techno
Trish she let a lame [ __ ] [ __ ] I won't
touch that [ __ ] emeralds busting
through my band I didn't cut my wrist
spin Lamborghinis in the sand don't give
a [ __ ] I'm rich 50 000 in my pants don't
give a [ __ ] how they fit the second time
they hit the crib I have to rush out to
10 it was 100 rack ill but I still got
my freedom so that's life and I'm right
tomorrow ain't promised [ __ ] we gotta
[ __ ] the night when I'll make some
McDonald's I'ma love your ass for life
on this beef you call my mama you can't
call none of my problems and my feelings
over nothing so don't talk to me yeah
driving this foreign I used to walk to
him this ain't the names I make Boss
music I put covered on the Press you
think I cost on it bought a mate back to
the hood they like Ross run them [ __ ]
can't show me a dollar they just talk
money don't say a word I just let the
money talk for me
moment of silence yeah scope on a rifle
yeah playing but I iced it
Pain still inside me a [ __ ] reached for
my neck we gonna catch a body she petite
with a protect when she exercising nope
oh okay
baby money
and that was a baby money Type Beat on
YouTube
go follow the homie man at baby money
wasagi baby money two underscores go run
that [ __ ] up go watch the full interview
too boolaycat.com
hey you just watched a crazy freestyle
and we drop one every week sometimes
more than once a week and they're always
presented by our family at LRG now I
love LRG I'm wearing look I'm gonna just
show you the new shorts I got from them
check out them shorts my boy you know
what I'm saying and got the plain black
tea the plain black LR GT you know what
I mean listen lrg's back they just
dropped the crazy Jason hoodie with
Jadakiss that's from my 2008 for
Halloween [ __ ] Flames go to the
website
l-r-g.com and this is crazy because
they're giving you 30 off when you use
the promo code bootleg 30 off that's a
significant amount of money you're going
to be saving when you go to lrg's
website Christmas is coming save 30 off
just by going to the website and using
the promo code bootleg L Dash R g.com
we'll see you next week with a crazy
freestyle